Ich führe wohl verschiedene Leben.
Ich habe verschiedene Hobbies,
mache gerne Musik.
Das ist für mich eine ganz andere Welt.
Ich gehe gerne mit Freunden weg.
Ich bin wohl in all diesen Situationen
ein anderer Mensch.
Aber das bedeutet ja noch nicht,
ein anderes Leben zu leben.
- Ich habe nicht alles erzählt.
- Ah, du hast ein heimliches Doppelleben.
Hallo zusammen, das ist "Bleisch & Bossart",
da sind wir wieder: Yves und Barbara.
Wir diskutieren Fragen aus philosophischer Sicht.
Auf diese gibt es meist keine Antwort,
darum streiten wir ab und zu.
Heute geht es um die Frage:
Wer bin ich und kann ich sein, wer ich sein will?
Yves, führst du das Leben, das du leben möchtest?
Grundsätzlich ja.
Ich kenne das Gefühl, zu träumen, schon.
Ich könnte auch Weinbauer
in der Provence sein.
- Weinbauer?
- Oder rauchend im Cabriolet durch Italien fahren.
Oder ich hätte Tennisprofi werden können.
Das kennt doch jeder. Du wohl auch?
Es gibt eine schöne Stelle
aus einem Roman von Margriet de Moor:
Sie sagt, sie habe festgestellt,
dass sich irgendwo um die nächste Ecke
ein Leben befindet,
von dem man irgendwann merkt:
Das hätte man genauso gut leben können.
Dieser Satz faszinierte mich immer,
denn das hat was.
Wenn man irgendwo eine andere Abzweigung
genommen hätte, wäre alles anders.
Was wäre dann? Wer wäre man?
Noch dieselbe Person oder ein anderer Mensch?
Beides. Ich glaube, man wäre anders geworden,
vielleicht sogar mit anderen Charakterzügen.
Ein anderer Habitus, andere Kleidung,
andere Sprache, andere Freunde.
Das glaube ich schon.
Aber als Person ist man wohl doch noch identisch.
Obwohl man sich über das Leben hinweg
auch sehr stark verändert.
Ich habe heute ganz andere Wünsche,
Überzeugungen und Ideale als vor 20 Jahren.
- Was hast du aufgegeben?
- Zum Beispiel die ganze Naivität.
Ich denke, das ist ein Reifeprozess.
Oder das Gegenteil - das müssen andere beurteilen.
Aber wir verändern uns.
Wichtig ist die Kontinuität,
dass es keine Brüche gibt.
Denn sonst, wenn jemand, keine Ahnung ...
... einen Unfall hat, Hirnverletzungen hat
und plötzlich aggressiv wird ...
- Oder zu einer Sekte geht.
- Genau.
Oder sich nicht mehr an früher erinnert, die
Erinnerung ist auch wichtig für die Kontinuität.
Dann kann man sagen:
"Ich bin noch dieselbe Person."
Obwohl sich meine Persönlichkeit verändert.
Das ist das Schiff des Theseus, dazu machten wir
ein "Filosofix"-Gedankenexperiment.
Das kann man nachschauen.
Die Idee ist, dass sich unsere Identität
zwar wandeln kann, aber langsam.
Wenn man die Planken eines Schiffes
über Nacht komplett austauschen würde,
wäre es ein anderes Schiff.
Aber wenn das Schiff immer wieder in die Werft
kommt, eine Planke nach der anderen ersetzt wird,
ist beim Schiff nichts mehr gleich wie beim alten -
und trotzdem ist es dasselbe.
Das ist eigentlich irritierend,
aber es geht um die Zeit.
Genau.
Kann man sich wirklich wesentlich verändern?
Mir fällt ein Theaterstück von Max Frisch ein,
ein für mich sehr philosophischer Autor.
"Biografie: Ein Spiel".
Er bekommt vom Spielleiter, eine Art Gottesfigur,
die Chance, sein Leben nochmals zu leben,
an einen bestimmten Punkt zurückzugehen,
anders zu handeln.
Und er macht alles immer wieder gleich.
Er tappt in dieselben Fallen.
Vielleicht ist es so: Auch wenn man sich vorstellt,
man hätte ein anderes Leben leben können,
nimmt man sich irgendwie doch mit -
zum Beispiel die genetische Ausstattung.
- Die wäre dann nicht anders.
- Ja.
Die Frage ist:
Was für ein Aggregatszustand hat unser Ich?
Ist es fest, flüssig oder gasförmig?
Wie sehr können wir uns gestalten?
Sind wir wie ein Stein oder eher wie Knete,
die man - oder das Leben - formen kann?
Die Meinungen gehen auseinander.
Ein Extrem ist der französische Existentialist
Jean-Paul Sartre, der sagt:
"Wir sind absolut frei."
Es gibt nichts, das uns einschränkt oder einengt.
Und wenn du das glaubst, täuschst du dich selbst.
Ein Kellner zum Beispiel,
der sich über seine Rolle als Kellner definiert,
muss sich bewusst sein, dass er jederzeit alles
abbrechen kann, seine Beziehungen, seinen Job,
auf die Bahamas auswandern
und Surflehrer werden.
Wir müssen lernen, diese Freiheit auszuhalten.
Sonst, sagt er, sei es eine Form von Feigheit.
Und selbst wenn uns beim Charakter etwas
unbewusst, genetisch mitgegeben wurde -
es gibt ja Studien, die besagen, dass ca. 50 %
von unserer Persönlichkeit schon früh festgelegt ist.
Das ist alles Selbstbetrug.
Genau. Sartre wandte sich mit seiner These
gegen die Psychoanalyse von Freud,
der in dieser Zeit gross war,
und sagte, das sei Habakuk:
Uns bestimmen nicht andere, unbewusste Dinge,
sondern: Wir sind radikal frei.
Er spricht von "mauvaise foi",
so etwas wie Selbsttäuschung.
Was ich an Sartres These sehr interessant finde:
Der Konformitätsdruck ist für ihn nicht etwas,
wogegen wir uns in erster Linie wehren müssen.
Es ist etwas, worin wir uns flüchten.
Er sagt, sich selbst zu sein, sei ein Taumel.
Und diesen Taumel halten wir nicht aus,
deshalb flüchten wir uns in die Konformität.
Wir wollen uns anpassen, weil frei
und sich selbst zu sein unglaublich schwierig ist.
Jeder Mensch muss sich das fragen. Ob man
unaufrichtig ist, ob es die mauvaise foi gibt.
Ob man nur ein feiges Leben lebt,
weil man den Mut nicht hat, zu sich selbst zu stehen.
Es kann in allen Lebenssituationen
solche Momente geben.
Konformitätsdruck
kann uns natürlich extrem einschränken.
Bei John Stuart Mill, dem liberalen Philosophen
des 19. Jh., kann man das gut nachlesen.
Die ganze Tyrannei der Mehrheit, die uns dazu
bringt, Dinge zu tun, zu sagen, zu denken,
und nicht frei zu sein, weil wir uns nicht trauen.
Es entsteht eine stromlinienförmige Gesellschaft
und alle tun dasselbe.
Heute besteht das Stromlinienförmige darin,
dass man speziell sein muss.
- Ja.
- Da kommen wir zu Andreas Reckwitz.
Der deutsche Soziologe sagt:
Hauptsache: speziell sein.
Er spricht von einer Explosion des Besonderen.
Die Frage "Wer bin ich eigentlich
und welche Leben würden zu mir passen?"
halte ich für eine der wichtigsten Fragen
unseres Lebens.
Schon bei Platon gibt es die Idee
"Gnothi seauton" - erkenne dich selbst.
Das ist der erste Imperativ des Philosophierens -
nebst dem Staunen über die Welt.
Das darf man
hinter dem Hype um Authentizität
und dem Narzissmus der Gesellschaft
nicht vergessen:
Der Grundimpetus ist richtig.
Sich selbst zu finden, vielleicht zu erfinden, aber so,
dass man sich damit identifizieren kann.
- Sich in einer Gesellschaft ausleben zu dürfen.
- Das finde ich sehr schön.
Da ist philosophisch viel vergraben.
Zugleich entsteht bei mir leichtes Unwohlsein
beim Ausdruck "sich selbst finden".
Das klingt, als ob es mich schon irgendwo gibt, und
wenn ich etwas grabe, finde ich mich irgendwann.
So sprechen wir auch:
beispielsweise vom Selbstfindungstrip.
Oder Menschen sagen:
"Ich stieg aus und habe mich endlich gefunden."
Aber für mich hat das etwas Bizarres.
Mir fällt hier die Philosophin Iris Murdoch ein,
die mal sagte:
"Man schaut nicht einfach hin und wählt etwas
und schaut, wohin man gehen könnte."
"Man steckt immer schon
bis zum Hals in seinem Leben."
Das hat damit zu tun, dass wir soziale Wesen sind,
wir sind nicht alleine.
Wir sind immer auch geprägt, in sozialen Verbünden.
Was mich ausmacht, sind oft Dinge,
die ich wie ein Schwamm aufgesogen habe.
Das sind fremde Elemente, die ich mir aneigne.
Aber trotzdem:
Ich glaube, diese Suche nach sich selbst gibt es.
Und das Ich ...
Vorhin sprach ich von Aggregatszustand.
Es ist nicht fix wie ein Stein,
es ist formbar, aber da ist etwas.
Man spürt manchmal: "Das bin nicht ich,
das passt nicht, ich verbiege mich."
Das ist die Intuition, die viele haben,
die irgendwann sagen: "Das stimmt nicht,
das bin nicht ich, das ist nicht mein Leben."
Das ist eine philosophische Urerfahrung.
Da kann man nicht postmodern sagen,
wir seien nur Konstruktionen und Geschichten.
- Das stimmt nicht.
- Du hast recht.
Heidegger spricht von der "Diktatur des Man".
Man sagt das ja so. Man lebt ja so. Man findet halt.
Das hat etwas. Es benötigt sehr viel Mut,
das eigene Leben zu leben.
Sich zu sagen: "Stopp, damit höre ich jetzt auf."
Was waren das für Momente bei dir?
Manchmal sind es Krisen, Gespräche oder ein Buch.
Oder es ist eine Leere,
vielleicht Ferien, drei Wochen nichts tun.
Wann hast du diese Gedanken?
Wann hast du zurückgeschaut und gedacht:
"Da änderte ich die Richtung."
Wie lange haben wir Zeit?
Nein, es ist ...
- Ich finde das interessant.
- Ja, das stimmt.
Je nachdem könnte man solche Situationen
ja auch suchen oder zumindest nicht meiden.
Was meiner Meinung nach stimmt: Karl Jaspers
sagt ja, in der Krise erkenne man sein wahres Ich.
Das stimmt für mich.
Krisenmomente sind sicher Umbruchmomente.
Eine Krise ist auch Ausdruck davon, dass man merkt,
man hat ein fundamentales Problem.
Lebenskrisen waren deshalb immer Momente,
um genauer zu verstehen, worum es mir geht.
- Du willst wissen, wann ich eine Krise hatte?
- Du musst es nicht erzählen, aber ja.
Nein, ich finde, das stimmt.
Aber ich habe auch den Verdacht,
dass es romantisierend ist.
Eine Krise bringt uns vielleicht
nicht nur näher zu uns selbst,
sie verändert uns auch.
Dann sind wir die,
die aufgrund der Krise so geworden sind.
Aber ob das das wahre Ich ist,
weiss man dann nicht, oder?
Wie ist das bei euch?
Lebt ihr das Leben, das ihr leben wollt?
Wir sind gespannt auf eure Kommentare
in der Kommentarspalte.
Wenn ihr nichts von "Bleisch & Bossart"
verpassen wollt, aktiviert die Glocke.
Wir sprachen auch mit anderen darüber: mit Sophie
Passmann und mit dem Philosophen Michael Hampe.
Diese Gespräche seht ihr hier.